[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we have
a special guest donald robertson we're
talking about
rebuilding plato's academy and donald we
will be telling us all about this those
who've been listening to us for a while
have heard us mentioning donald from
time to time he is a very important
figure in the modern stoic movement
which we're going to talk about a bit as
well but he's also got a very
interesting new project going so welcome
to the show donald it's really great to
have you here
it's a real treat for all of us well
hello thank you greg and thank you dan
and uh i hope you're saying nice things
about me greg i wasn't around like
i trust buddy so i'm sure i'm looking
forward to our chat today because like i
said we've got a bunch of different
things we could potentially talk about
so anything could happen yeah and this
by the way is our 50th episode of the
wisdom for life show so it's kind of a
fun milestone
as well so we should do some
introductions first um donald robertson
is a cognitive behavior
therapy practitioner he's an author a
speaker he is a founding member of what
eventually became known as the modern
stoicism organization
and he's organized some of the big
stoicon conferences which uh listeners
of the show have heard us talk about and
i think that you've spoken at pretty
much every one of them right
has there been one where you there was
one we were talking about earlier where
you got held up at the border and almost
didn't make it in but you did make it in
i made it there and then i think i've
spoke i don't know i might have spoken
uh i think i've spoken at too many of
them like
i think people are getting i'll have to
come up with some new things to talk
about i've spoken at a lot of
conferences
and i was going to say like i've done a
lot of podcasts somebody this is this
guy that i know sent me a playlist and
he's like donald made this playlist of
all the podcasts you've done and it was
over a hundred
you know sometimes i use expletives
like
but honestly
you think you would improve like
with like a fine line or something
podcasts are like cable tv though you
can you can say whatever you want on
them and they're not gonna the fcc is
not gonna get on your case whereas like
the radio show like we're doing here you
know obviously we have to stick with the
uh don't say the seven deadly words
um i i do wanna finish the rest of the
introduction uh for for donald though um
for people who don't
haven't haven't seen his stuff he he
created one of the largest online stoic
communities that's been going now for
quite a while a massive facebook group
which uh i know has been a lot of work
uh for you over the years he's also the
author of a number of books i'll just
mention three of them stoicism the art
of happiness practical wisdom for
everyday life
the philosophy of cognitive behavior
therapy stoic philosophy is rational and
cognitive psychotherapy and that's very
well done greg you said the full title
there yeah well
i've got it right there in front of me
so it's one of the longest book titles
in history is it really
i think so i like to i like to tell
myself that well your your your other
one's pretty long too how to think like
a roman emperor the stoic philosophy of
marcus aurelius that's uh pretty
sizeable right i have to do that because
in case people thought i was talking
about another roman empire it's sneaky
it tricks up like i thought i said how'd
you think a roman emperor and they think
well it can't give us something and they
said no read the subtitle and they go oh
right yeah you're right
so
is it you that is the big fan of the
subtitles or is that your publisher i
think it's me i i think that i think my
publishers are kind of somewhat a little
bit
they do they're not super keen on my
book titles like usually but i'll tell
you a little story about that sure
a long time ago
i
the very first book proposal i did
i was turned down
um by this kind of psychotherapy panel
that was looking to publish books and
then the acquiring editor told me to
send it straight to the publishing house
and i did and they turned it down as
well so i was a businessman at a time
around the training school i i phoned up
the publisher and i said hey what kind
of books do you want people to write and
they said we'd like someone to write a
book about philosophy and cognitive
behavioral therapy so i changed the
title of the book to the philosophy of
cogs and i sent them the same proposal
back and they faxed me back my first
book contract but that book was called
how to fit my roman emperor and it took
me like 12 years or something like that
before i got a chance to pitch another
book with the same title and it was
published and it did really well and
it's been published translated into 18
languages now and uh
i think the title works really well but
it was turned down and it took me like
10 or 15 years before i got a chance to
get a publisher to accept it
well i think there's a lot of stories
out there about um on the one hand
manuscripts that go to publisher after
publisher after publisher getting
rejected constantly and then finally
something clicks and then
yeah there's there's a lot of
projects where it really depends on how
you pitch it doesn't it it's though
there's an art i'm always a bit
suspicious i was a uh
i think about positive psychology and
there was a guy given this kind of
motivational speech in england years ago
and he told the story about how he wrote
a self-help book with his business
partner about positive psychology and he
said he submitted it to a publishing
house and he turned it down he submitted
another one he submits another one and
he submitted it to like 50 publishers
before it was finally accepted yeah and
and it goes and so the moral of this
story is you know you like william
wallace you know if us at first you
don't sick or robert bruce if at first
you don't succeed try try try again
right and everyone's stuck in the
[ __ ] clap and i turned around and
looked at my wife at the time and then
she was looking at me and we were both
like this is the stupidest story i've
ever had in my life because like if he's
got ton down 50 times like you know
maybe like there's something wrong with
the book like and maybe he's kind of
scraping the barrel now for publishing
houses that would publish it you know
so like normally if i said if i sent a
proposal and then the publisher turned
it down two or three times i probably
asked them why they were toning it down
like and then normally you'd have a lot
of conversation and maybe it's kind of
like a just a proposal or whatever
that's an example of somebody doing
something that doesn't work and then
they just keep doing it which normally
these guys tell you is like a bad
strategy in life
you know it's better to get feedback and
adapt to it and stuff like that stuff
what happened the whole thing about
getting feedback and figuring out what
it was you're doing wrong and learning
from it i just keep doing the same thing
50 times
right that was it anyway that was a good
strategy and i thought that i don't i
don't think that's a good strategy for
getting books published but hey you know
what would i know probably not a good
strategy in general right they've got a
lot of equip about uh madness is doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result i would say
the gossip was it heidegger no no no
definitely not
you know
i i've heard that attributed to einstein
but who knows you know they think that's
one of those quotes that just kind of
floats around yeah it's like fork wisdom
or something i think there's
this passage in epictetus that i really
really like because you do see a lot of
people in the stoic community saying
just keep at it don't don't allow
anything to get you down and he says
stubbornness is not uh the same thing as
as prudence so he was talking about some
guy who decided to do something it was
something bad and he stuck to it and
people are saying oh look at this guy
he's persevering and epictetus says no
he's not this is just uh foolishness you
know you have to actually have something
good that you decide on and then keep
sticking to it over and over again if
you're just if you're just deciding to i
don't know
go to the gym and lift too many weights
you know you're not actually getting any
better at things doing that or you know
walk in front of cars and you know
expect the cars to stop that that's just
foolishness
yeah makes me think a little bit of
you know kind of the idea of praxis here
we have theory plus practice if you're
just practicing away without any theory
then you're not going to actually you'll
make any progress towards something that
you actually a goal that you're looking
for um although i guess a a counter
example would be
dune and frank herbert
basically exhausted every single uh
publishing house that actually published
novels so he went to
another one automotive manufacturer
right yeah
and
and somehow they they found this and so
either you've got something that's so
um kind of transformative um that people
don't realize it's it's greatness or
you're doing something wrong um and the
question is how do you determine the
difference yeah exactly how how could
you tell the difference between those
two i could you're right it could be
that this did self-help book a bit
positive psychology with it was an epoch
making masterpiece
that is it was simply
like ages beyond its time or something
like that i think but maybe maybe not it
may not have been but they i didn't know
that about frank there are i will
happily concede that there are some
authors that that strategy works out for
um i was going to say you know like
sometimes people say if you could go
back in time you could go back in time
you could speak to any philosopher
that's been dead for a long time like
who would you want to have a beer with
or something like that is something that
people sometimes ask them on podcasts
have you ever asked anyone that question
greg um no i've never asked anyone that
question but i haven't been asked i have
been asked that question and i have a
hard time answering it because i know i
i step this difficult question right
yeah
who did you can't speak the same
language yeah like that would make it
awkward it would be like awkward silence
and they might know that they might not
like beer too you know like
foreign to have a beer with or whatever
like he was about he was kind of quite i
was a little bit stiff and a little bit
of a nerdy kind of guy socrates would be
awesome but the thing that i really want
to go back and see
is
allegedly and this is in one of these
kind of chunky roman histories that we
don't trust that much i think if you
remember right it's in the history of
gustaf but it might be true why
does it says
um
the
hatred
was besties
with epictetus
yeah which is the most
like the odd couple right
like it's the most unlikely like
in my mind hadrian
like who is probably one of the most
arrogant men in history
like
and and epictetus who's always going on
about not flattering tyrants and stuff
like that
and the idea of these two guys
having a chinwag i would love to be a
fly in the wall because i don't actually
i don't i don't actually believe that
like i think hey maybe hadrian told
everyone that epictetus was his bestie
and epic jesus was like oh my god not
that guy
like or epic he just didn't even know
that he was saying it he's like epic
he's display hadrian who
you know it's it's funny because it
brings to mind um the you know famous
encounter between alexander and diogenes
um and and we we find these texts later
on that have to become they they can't
possibly be the actual uh dialogues um
like uh diocassion telling us the the
the discourses between the two of them
and maybe they had some sort of contact
with each other right um who knows uh
it's but you're but you're right to be a
fly on the wall you know to actually get
to hear it i'll tell you something about
diogenes cynic right so he didn't the
they can't even agree about whether he
wrote any books or not right so you may
have written but we didn't leave any
behind right
um
but we have all these anecdotes and
stuff about them now where do those
anecdotes come from well we know like
because the several of the historians
tell us that a bunch of them come from
satires right so we're literally told
that they were only joking
like when they said a lot of these
things they're satirical place yeah
right
um and yet we kind of treat them as a
literal truth so some of them maybe are
or even satis can be kind of grounded
sometimes there are things that are
going on that end up
coming out to be true but we we should
bear that in mind when we're listening
to stories about diogenes the cynic is
that they
a lot of what we all that we know about
them really are these anecdotes and a
number of them and possibly more than we
realized seem to come from satirical
plays
yeah
so to finish up your introduction here
good 15 minutes in the show
um you've also got a brand new project
the uh the new plato's academy um
can you tell us a little bit about that
well i was saying to greg earlier
like
we said we're seeing how it happened
that we got into doing this thing and
it was because i was in athens and i was
doing a lot of podcasts and people would
say to me where are you donald and i say
oh i'm in athens and greece and they say
well what tell us about or what have you
been doing so i'd say i could say well i
just went and got a kebab or whatever
but i'd say well some more interesting i
went the other day to plato's academy
park right and they'd say what's that
like and then i get all animated and i
kind of shoot my mouth off and i'd say
well i just couldn't believe
that there isn't really much that much
are like i thought there should be an
international conference center at the
original location of plato's academy
that seems like a no-brainer to me right
and it's an economically deprived area
there's a little digital museum and
there's a statue of plato and there are
ruins there it's a recreational ground
that all the athenians are not that many
tourists go there
but there's nothing um
much else there and there could be who
wouldn't want to go to a conference at
the original location of plato's academy
but everybody's heard of it's like
coca-cola like everyone's heard of the
academy if only because every other
academy is uh name-checking it like is
named after it yeah so i kind of said
that enough times that people
and i was only
kind of shooting my mouth off and then
people
started emailing me and stuff and saying
oh i i'd be interested in um
kind of like supporting that project or
like often like investing in it and
and then luckily because i know a lot of
people in greece and stuff
i know um i'm good friends with the
general manager of the american school
for classical studies in athens which is
the main foreign archaeological
institute in athens pantelas panos and
uh i sat and had coffee and i was
chatting to him about it i said tell us
i've been sh i'll be shooting my mouth
off on podcasts and i've been talking
about how there should be an
international conference in the plato's
academy like don't you think that's a
crazy idea and he said no that's quite a
good idea like
and then we we got other people involved
luckily i know a guy who's a chartered
surveyor who specializes in these kind
of things and i realized i kind of knew
a lot of people
um and then before long and i said
before long because we we're still just
about to incorporate with um our
incorporation is pretty much done it
should be uh finished like in the next
few days but we already now have seed
funding we're enrolled in an incubator
program we've got a whole board of
advisors with a bunch of senior
academics and authors and stuff
um we're already running several
events or involved in running several
major events in athens next year
and we set up our website and all our
social media accounts we just had two
thousand people enroll in our email less
than 500 people over the weekend join
the group that we just set up so
everything just kind of exploded
really and then the more
we got people on board the more they
started telling they started shooting
their mouths off from podcasts about
like
and then other everyone else would start
talking about and then people would say
to me
when i talk to them they'd say hey
whatever happened to that plate was
academy thing that you mentioned and
we'd be like well we're kind of like
start doing that actually you know um
we're in the process of doing that now i
said we should rebuild plato's academy
and then but i was kind of speaking
somewhat figuratively because like we
don't know exactly what it looked like
or where exactly where it was but we
know that roughly i should explain here
i will have a little mini history lesson
right
so
athens had three gymnasium like and so
we call a gymnasium like what like in a
sports hall right
um but a gymnasium in ancient greece is
more like what we would call a
recreational ground it's a park like and
within it there would be a polyester i
like our wrestling school there'll be a
running track there'll be streams and
walks and weirdly to us
uh people would young adolescent boys
would go there to
exercise naked and middle-aged men would
go there to talk about philosophy and
argue with sophists and whatnot right so
it was kind of they were kind of weird
places that we don't really have an
equivalent of today it was a mixture of
philosophy and athletics
and
the academy was one of them and then
play took him along and he founded his
school there and he would walk in the
park and talk to his students the other
building there and also he was buried
there like his uh his tomb was in the
park his bones are maybe still under the
ground they are somewhere i like to
think
and so we have the ruined foundations
there are some of the buildings we think
one's a palestine we're not entirely
sure what some of the other ones are
it's a nice area in the summer but it's
a poor area of athens
and the government have just announced
plans to build a new archaeological
museum there to landscape the park to
improve it for tourists and we said we
could just have a building
adjacent to it facing the park and
overlooking it and
which is as a conference facility
and i said i'll tell you here's another
here's a story within a story in the
1970s the american director and actor
sam wannamaker went to london
and he thought london's cool if you're
an actor this is where shakespeare did
these plays originally in the globe
theater
um and some want to make her went to
look for the globe theater and it wasn't
they are like they found a little plaque
it said this is roughly where we think
the globe might have been and somewhere
i want to make a thought that's pathetic
rightly so he thought that this is crazy
why don't they just build a replica of
it it would be an amazingly unique
building it's thatched roof and it's
round it's open air it's like a really
bizarre thing and people thought he was
crazy he spent decades fundraising for
any built the globe theater and the
south bank of the thames and it's now
one of the main
tourist attractions in london it's got
exhibits and an event space and a
restaurant and they perform plays there
and stuff like that and so i said to the
athenians what i told them this story
and they understood it and they were
like yeah why don't we do that with
plato's academy why don't we build at
least a kind of event space where people
can come and do philosophy
and then actually it would attract
foreign revenue into greece which would
be good for the economy and they would
improve the the area so it's a
non-profit venture it's a social
enterprise that could benefit the
surrounding area so that was the basic
idea behind that
and then we realized it was going to
take us a little while to so people said
well donald there's a pandemic on have
you not noticed like and i was and i
thought well i like to see i'm kind of
paradoxical guy you know i i like to see
what everyone else sees as a kind of
setback i like to think that maybe
secretly it's an opportunity
right so i thought we were right this
pandemic on but this is a good time to
start this project because it's going to
take us several years probably before
we'd be able to open the premises and
finish renovating them and stuff anyway
and the property prices are relatively
low at the moment so actually it's quite
a good time to begin doing this project
and in the meantime we
will get the virtual community off the
grounds like can we build up our online
presence so we can promote do virtual
events and then promote the physical
location when it's ready and also in
between we because it's a park and
because it's greece we can do open-air
events and so the athenian
local authority is organizing the some
are some open air events which we've
been uh talking to them about
participating in so that's the whole
story greg there you go well we should
mention so for anybody who's listening
who wants to be able to see what
donald's talking about plato's
academy.org very simple straightforward
web address
and
there's a lot more to the story i think
but i do want to ask you about something
so when i was looking at precisely what
you're talking about this
well-structured we're going to do this
first and then that's going to lead to
this and then to this it seems like
you're you're planning on not only
looking for you know support both from
governments and from individuals and
institutions but you're you're thinking
about how to use
um
what you're taking in as revenue to push
things through the next steps and so the
two
the two things that came to mind for me
especially knowing that it is in an
economically depressed area where this
is probably going to bring some jobs in
and
you know influx of money into the
community especially if you get foreign
tourists spending money there so there's
this is an exercise of prudence which is
an important virtue whether we're
talking about platonic virtue ethics or
aristotelian or stoic
but it's also about building and
benefiting
community as such
and it strikes me that
you know choosing to to do it in a place
instead of like you know finding the
poshest place you can possibly have for
conference goers doing not quite the
opposite but doing something where it's
actually going to be in a community
where i suppose some people would be
like ah these philosophy people coming
in what are they what are they actually
going to do for us i i want to know that
philosophy is going to be very practical
um
seems like a good thing to me
well there's a kind of greek thing about
that i think which is it seems to me i
if i can make a generalization without
offending i don't think my greek friends
would be offended but i think they kind
of agree there's a kind of like there's
a sort of mixed feeling about philosophy
and greece so some people are a little
bit jaded with it because they it's part
like they get a bit of it at school and
they're upbringing and stuff and they
think of kind of not philosophy again
like you know we've had we've heard all
that you know kind of before but there's
another current in in greek culture
that's extremely proud of its heritage
um and so can i in greek people often
tell me they've got greek people aren't
interested in philosophy nobody's really
into that anymore but then every almost
every single one of them i've spoken to
like get is really into it and i tell
that's my great [ __ ] well the other
great people i speak to i can't get away
from them they're standing for hours try
to get a haircut or whatever or buy a
pair underpants or something and they're
talking to me about pythagoras and
things like that you know i if i get
trapped like and they go well that's
just the people you speak to though
donald and i'm like well i don't know i
don't think that's true like every so
far virtually every and i met quite a
lot of great yeah
almost every one of them that i've met i
think it's almost like that kind of
concealing the fact that secretly
underneath like you know they're
actually quite passionate about
philosophy and stuff so i think maybe
some people have mixed feelings about
you know foreign businesses and you know
maybe the commercialization of it but i
think it's important that this is a
non-profit organization and we're doing
it in collaboration with local
institutions um and we have a number of
greek individuals uh on a board of
advisors or a board of directors and
stuff like that we try to kind of do
that from the outset i also think it's
important that and i think the greeks
that spoke kind of sympathized with us
that i felt it
it made sense that it would be
partly people from outside greece
that would kind of have some suggestions
about the way to go about doing this
because i think what the greeks feel is
that they have all these amazing assets
cultural assets but they've struggled
for years to know how to for whatever
kind of better words it's a bit of a
crass way
but to kind of monetize them basically
or to actually use them in a way that
would benefit the economy so the
acropolis museum they've done a really a
good job of turning into a major tourist
attraction um but things like plato's
academy park is world famous and yet it
just kind of like sits there and tunes
don't really come to it and so they kind
of want to know like what would
americans or british people or whatever
want what would make them come here
and so i think i i was maybe able and my
some of my friends were able to bring a
little bit of perspective
uh
to the sort of things that might be
appealing from an outsider perspective
is there going to be so i mean plato's
academy the one of the main um you know
gymnasia um is there going to be
anything connecting down the line to you
know the kuno sarge or
you know the stall poikilay or you know
you can join them all together well i
could join the dots of like i feel like
maybe there would be like a tour to go a
secret tunnel yeah
yeah though i see um like well the thing
is that they didn't like each other
so they're quite spaced apart
so like i mean i don't know if you like
when aristotle opened the school he did
it on the other side of athens later
like
so they they're kind of like this they
try to get far away from each other as
they could for some reason or maybe it's
just for those of us who haven't been
there how far are these from each other
well not like i mean well it's a modern
city so you've kind of got to get
through the city saying and stuff so you
might your main problem is you may get
stuck in a traffic jam for ages or
whatever right but is it is the crow
flies
i guess where would we go to from the
lyceum to plato's academy is someone can
google this i would think it's about
just under an hour's walk 45 minutes
okay well i'd say for maybe 45 i'm
getting a roughly 45 minute walk if you
were able to to make a a straight shot
of it
um which in modern times isn't that much
but athens was much smaller actually you
know back back in the days that was the
um outside the city walls on like the
the other side of the city
so um
yeah you could i mean i've often thought
for some reason this is a recurring
thing that people are always like what
if you had a philosopher's tour and you
could get in a little mini bus and we
could all drive around and like we could
see what socrates drank the hemlock then
we could
go into the house where plateau lived
and like you know and yeah you can
totally do that one of the weird things
is there are i think people that do that
but generally when you go to greece
though the that stuff isn't really
highlighted so without a
shadow of doubt most people who go there
would look at the acropolis and stuff
and think that looks really cool but
they wouldn't really
get much of a sense of how
um some of these locations link into the
history of philosophy so i can go by the
way i'll just i'll give you a quick off
the top of my head right sure uh kenneth
our case there isn't anything they are
right we don't really there's just a
suburb there's i don't think there's any
archaeological remnants there from what
i recall plato's academy park there are
some ruins and the actual park is there
and stuff there's that the acropolis
there's the theater dionysus on the side
where aristophanes performed the clouds
so that you can literally see the
the stands the bench where socrates
socrates is sat so socrates you can put
your bum where socrates's bum was
like when he was watching this play
where they were roasting him as we could
say today
on this people would go there to laugh
at socrates so you can too
like and you'll you'll submit you'll
notice some interesting things when you
do that and
then uh
where there's the lyceum which there's
only a small part of the lysium now but
it's very well preserved it's in a
slightly more up market part of athens
and the lyceum like these parks were not
we associate them in a reductionist
manner greg and dan play with we think
that i see him as aristotle school and
the academy is plato's school but that's
not really entirely true because other
philosophers taught there as well chris
ipis greg taught at lyceum and before
aristotle was a johnny come lately on
the scene like before he taught the
lyceum socrates discussed philosophy
there and some of these probably went uh
and taught at the academy as well and
produce
uh oh no sorry protagoras um read his
famous
that um
uh is it on the gods the one where he
says i'm not really sure if they exist
or not and the athenians were like oh
we're not having that well and they've
gone these books and put them on trial
and all like so protagoras like this
first kind of right i know agnostic kind
of thing that got him in a lot of
trouble he he read that it'll i see him
as i recall and uh so you can go and see
those things and then just outside of
athens maybe
like
about an hour's drive from athens
there's elf cena or ellucis okay where
are the allisonian mysteries were
conducted there's a sculpture of marcus
aurelius probably marcus willis i think
it's maxwellis which was above the
entrance gate
because
marcus aurelius
was
um
that that temple was littered by
a summation tribe um that came all the
way down through the balkans and looted
it during the marker man it was and
mark's released when he went to athens
at the end of his life said i'm going to
fix something and have it repaired
because i really like ls mysteries like
it resonates with stoicism and he felt
rebuilt the gate at the front with big
statue of him above it and that statue
still remains over the head fell off
recently by but you can still you can go
and check that the big temple grounds
there and everything and elusive that's
quite important to the history of
philosophy and then delphi who are uh
cairofon socrates friend that's a maybe
a couple of days johnny i think it's
a two hour two and a half hour drive
from athens into the mountains
there's the temple of apollo where the
pithia the priestess um
of apollo would sit on the tripod and
inhale the fumes and say no man is wiser
than socrates and everybody have a good
laugh
like and then and then a few years later
they they
like this joke's not funny anymore like
make him drink hemlock
and you know that you know you know how
the rest is so exciting how it all ended
but that she was very important but i
think the temple of apollo is far more
important than people realized to the
the history of philosophy plutarch says
it was like he said the
um we're told by a number of sources
that pythagoras learned his moral
philosophy from one of the priestesses
uh at the temple of apollo one of the
pithiers um now that's interesting
because there aren't many people keep
saying there aren't many women in
ancient philosophy but there are but
they're all kind of on the periphery
yeah and these kind of then they're the
most interesting characters why
so it may be that one of the very
earliest moral philosophers we're told
was not pythagoras but it's not the
woman that taught him
like and it came from the god apollo
because the god apollo spoke for her and
the two most famous maxims every
philosopher knows greg
like there were 147 delphic maxims
they're like zen coans because many of
them are just two words in greek and
plutarch says although they're very
short and sweet they're just like little
seeds the cryptic
many volumes of books have been written
explaining them so they kind of were
just little strange ideas that that
triggered all this reflection it's what
fueled philosophy trying to understand
these things and the two most famous
ones were genotha seout on which means
no thyself and made an again which means
nothing in excess and those were the
ones that were carved in the pillar
before you even went in
and the philosophers would argue about
what they mean now know thyself is
obviously
like a kind of a
of ancient philosophy particularly in
the socratic tradition but so is made in
again nothing in excess the idea of
temperance and moderation is is very
much a
motif in in throughout ancient moral
philosophy and in great culture even
today it's something that people um
often refer to so this this temple of
apollo was churning out these kind of
seeds of philosophy yeah like and kind
of was this kind of factory kind of like
sort of fueling the philosophy industry
like so you can go there and you can
look at that's an amazing archaeological
site and then uh those are like i guess
i've probably forgotten some ruin now
that i'm gonna
get into trouble for not mentioning but
those are like those are basically the
main ones are philosophical coming back
to athens what is there still left of
the store poikilay is there anything or
no because people keep asking me about
that right and i try to explain this
without being too blunt but so they say
why do clips padme why not do the store
quickly well i was going to ask you
about that this was nothing there like
it's a big dirty hole in the ground
right so we have
it's it is there i don't mean to be
dismissive about right very important
it's an important archaeological site
the problem is
like the athenians built the city center
on top of it
like
so and they built a railroad next to it
as well why
so they
there is a
um uh what's called a plot that that's
been excavated okay surrounded by
tavernas and shops and stuff like that
and the the tourist uh district and
there's not much to see there's a few
kind of ruins but you can't you can't
walk in it normally um
so you just have to look through you
appear through a fence and there's a lot
of graffiti and a few cats and stuff so
it's not like you can what the ancient
agora you can walk all over oh i forgot
to mention
the ancient agora is one of the most
important locations in terms of history
yeah um at the foot of the acropolis
because socrates obviously did
philosophy there socrates we think
actually um was tried and and executed
in a building in the agora
and uh i mentioned earlier like satires
so well i'm digressing slightly but one
of the things that's always a i found
fascinating about history is
your historical texts are very
unreliable right and so historians will
read things like satires and they'll
think well that looks like it's probably
not true you know i mean this guy said
that but we can't really trust it so
there's this legend about simon the show
maker who is supposedly good friends
with socrates socrates was known for
going into tradesmen's workshops they
say we'd hang out in the koblos shop in
the agora talk to this guy simon he
supposedly wrote some of the earliest
socratic dialogues that are all lost now
cause it wasn't just plato that wrote
them there were
it was a whole genre after his death and
simon wrote on the first ones but people
think this looks like a literary trope
because socrates is well known for going
barefoot so the idea that he spent all
day in a shoemaker's shop just talking
you know trash about philosophy and then
this guy poor guy is sitting there
thinking would you just buy a pair of
sandals and then leave
these are people though who have never
spent much time like sitting in a barber
shop or maybe that's true
or things like that because
you're kind of you're you're constantly
beset with people who are you know just
sitting around not purchasing anything
you get they get a haircut eventually
they never bought a pair of shoes once
and so people thought this sounds made
up
like it sounds convenient
well they found they are they
archaeologists
found
um
a little shop they found lots of little
shops and one of them they found nails
for making boots okay yeah why and if
this is a cobbler shop and then they
found the bottom of a helix like a greek
uh cup um and sometimes greeks would
carve their name scratch their name on
the
like terracotta base of the the helix
this one had the name simon scratched on
it which is quite eerie like imagine
being the guy that takes that out of the
ground yeah this is
and you can see that in the uh i think
it's exhibited in the uh
museum of the position
i'll tell you one other little thing
about that in the place where they think
socrates was executed you can see this
on
being exhibited in the museum there they
found a statuette of socrates of the
kind that would normally be displayed in
the shrine so it's an athenian stood
there sometimes it's almost like they
felt guilty
about executing him and then and built
shrine to him later in the in the prison
they had a little statue dedicated to
him that they they found in the in the
ground there well that's not a surprise
oh go ahead dan i was not alaska i've
got a question this raises from yeah uh
so
i think the the choice especially the
the
plato's academy is a great one
especially when we're talking in
reference to
uh shakespeare and the globe theater um
you can't get anywhere in the western
philosophical tradition without talking
about either socrates or plato you
either have to
either affirm or reject him but you
can't just ignore him um or if you
ignore him then
that is also taken as you are
intentionally ignoring him because how
could you not right oh you're not
yeah
he's the elephant in the room or
something like plato's obviously yeah
he's the alpha exactly and so
it makes perfect sense um from a like at
least a marketing standpoint that uh not
only is anyone that's interested in
greek philosophy but anyone in the film
the western philosophical tradition has
to have at least some idea of what this
of these uh fosters uh plato and
socrates where um and have to reference
them and so it's in my mind it's more uh
has more potential than even the
acropolis yeah i've only ever met one
guy that never heard of socrates and he
was australian i don't know if that says
anything about it
i'd play so that was that's just like
that that's the fact i met this guy once
and it was an australian buddy of mine
and he's like i was talking about
socrates and he was like who's that i
was like how can you put socrates the
greek philosopher like he's never heard
of me like and that's the only guy i've
ever met that was just straight up
everyone said a plato but everyone's
everyone's heard of even everyone said
the plato's academy and even if they
hadn't dan
well you'd be like you've heard of
academies right like the common noun
right and they're like obviously and
they'll be like well it's named after
the the
literally the name of the place where
the thing is did they do right and so
they they everybody understands what the
academy is and you go look even if you
don't know anything about philosophy do
not think it'd be pretty cool to be able
to go and study stuff at the original
archaeological
archaeological location this is
literally the first academy after which
every other academy is named
yeah you get to have kebabs
and you get to go and swim with the
fishes in the ocean and enjoy a nice
sunshine and all that there's a lot of
people yeah that sounds like a cool
holiday but basically they don't do
philosophy there's not much philosophy
going on there anymore really and you
know part of the idea was very simply
could we not get people doing philosophy
there again yeah and this what type of
philosophy
right yeah
like from what i've read so far of
yourself it seems that you've got the
idea for conferences and like kind of
like a general place to meet um but are
we here's a course i'm actually gonna go
back to the idea of more than just
discourse but also on any sort of uh
teaching going on
yes and no like because for
there are
there are some
legal um and kind of practical obstacles
to starting a school
so at least in the interim it's easier
for us to run conferences than to create
a teaching establishment right but there
may be ways to work with that let's say
so there are some complications that are
kind of legally practically because the
bureaucracy of
how things work in greece the conference
option is easier so in terms of teaching
philosophy i think one of the obstacles
so
all great ideas you think why hasn't
someone done this already right and the
answer to that is because if somebody
had done this already they would have
got a professor
in philosophy from one of the great
universities to give a powerpoint
slideshow about plato's theory of forums
right and nobody would fly from america
to see that i think or not many people
greg would but nobody else would right
and would you dan come on our plane all
the way it's like 12 hours or something
like that you would do okay well you
guys
not that many people like would do that
so i said like the thing is
we have to use plato as a trojan's horse
right i mean this is a secret don't tell
anyone that's right well you're on the
air talking about it i'm not telling you
enough right but we're using plato as a
kind of trojan's horse and you know
what's inside that trojan horse greg can
you guess what's inside that natural
it's hidden inside it's not dcs it's
socrates where socrates is hidden inside
that children's host of plato right
because i don't have a problem like
because we're mean so us not only
obviously but we have xenophon and all
stuff as well but our main source for
our socrates is plato so we say you came
for the plateau but we stayed for the
socrates kind of thing right so i'm not
i don't want to bore people to death
with plato's theory or formers we can
get people discussing that and stuff but
it's not something that lights modern
people off i are really because poets
and mystics love it but people don't see
pluto's theory forms as being a down to
earth pragmatic philosophy for modern
living and it's also something that you
don't have to be somewhere to do right i
mean you could you could talk about
plato's theory forms anywhere so yeah
so i think what we want is the method
right we want the socratic method like
we want dialectic and i also i'm going
to say something else it's paradox like
socrates paradox from paradox here right
i'm going to suggest
that it's not just the kind of cognitive
aspect of the methodology it's like the
questioning technique and stuff like
that that's important
but i'm going to say i agree with
something that epictetus said that
another weird epitaph was a weird guy he
said a lot of weird things
right
so he said because he said for example
one of the weirdest things he said
there's a passage in the discourses but
he tells his students that living like a
beggar is good for your health because
he said look around you and notice how
many really old bagels you see
it must be good for you they wouldn't
love to be that old right which is one
of the most bonkers arguments like i've
ever come across right right so he did
say some really weird stuff but he says
something shocking about socrates he
says to his students
what is this um
you know like uh
400 years 500 years like uh after the
death of socrates he says societies is
like ancient history to him he says he's
still going on about the guy right and i
picked his stances students and he says
you guys should be like socrates
repeatedly he tells them that
and he says you know that he says over
and over again like you should live like
soccer you should try and be like
socrates um
and he said he they say can you usage
chickalee
at one point they say hey teacher are
you a sage like and he says i'm not but
i can point to somebody who might be and
then he taught her really he references
diogenes and socrates so he's obsessed
with socrates he's a massive fanboy for
socrates and then he tells the students
you know one of the main things that you
guys could learn from socrates and not
like not go and tell us has it got
something to do with being really old
and being a beggar and all that why
because we're not interested as he says
no it's not that why he says socrates
would show you how to be able to have a
philosophical debate without
degenerating into a squabble
which many people would think is ironic
because socrates get executed for having
philosophical debates obviously right
but epic doesn't see the irony in that
effect socrates is really good at having
a debate with people without upsetting
them now that is kind of true
paradoxically this guy that's famous for
being executed for upsetting people
generally in plato he's portrayed as
being incred having a really good
debating etiquette he's he's very polite
he's very generous often
um he's very patient
with his interlocutors in many cases but
he has good humor about it as well like
that's one of the most bizarre things
about socrates he's the most good human
of all philosophers in a sense he's um
you know um
most relaxed and nietzsche uh even
commented on that there's something
about his character uh and his sense of
humor and irony that marks him out from
other philosophers now epictetus says
that's the main thing we could learn
from him why do i think that's so
important greg why do i think it's more
important than plato's theory of forms
or even the
the questioning aspect of the
structural aspect of the socratic method
well because of the internet
and the painful effects right yeah that
the internet has for a number of
psychological reasons
social psychology the internet is
turning us all
into as you described as you put it
earlier a-holes
right
i so people go on the internet yeah and
they argue with each other they're
impatient they're intolerant they're
incapable in many cases of having a
proper rational
debate like it's full of confirmation
bias and other cognitive biases they
don't know how to frame questions well
then nobody ever changes their mind
about anything like and so it ends up
being the opposite of what the socratic
method was like so what i'd like to do
is bring back
the civil discourse like the tolerance
of disagreement and those aspects of the
socratic method and and as a a counter
balance in a way to what the social
media has has done to our culture
so one of the things that you're talking
about is having a virtual
portion to this yes and so i was
wondering if you'd like is that
something along the lines of zoom like
what we're doing right now or is that
also something along the lines of maybe
something more immersive uh something vr
yeah actually that's something that
we've been talking about so there's
always people that are very keen on the
kinemata stuff in the like using virtual
reality that yeah that's a possibility
people are very interested in doing that
in greece like reconstructing it
virtually and also having virtual
conferences
and maybe video calls and things but
also text based like i feel like we need
to nail
um and we can nail uh
you know the just traditional text
basically i don't think they're going
away actually you know contrary to what
uh many people think i think people will
continue to use
uh
discussion forums like they use bulletin
boards in the past they'll use videos
virtual reality they're still just type
things but i think people could learn to
do that
in a more civil constructive intolerant
manner so partly there's a certain
civility of it there's the etiquette of
it
um
does the
you know the questioning method does
patience is tolerance does managing it's
all about the virtual temperance in a
way it's about managing your anger and
not getting upset yeah
with other people not getting the hump
with them just because they disagree
with you which is
something that people are finding harder
and harder today
um
well it's but it's also about critical
thinking in general sorry dan i'm just
going to say we also want to teach
people how to spot fallacies and stuff
like that right
so you almost never
have a conversation or you're trying to
talk about something that's especially
deeply held that you'll almost never see
them change their their belief
in a single conversation that that's
rather unless they've already been doing
something else but um there's usually a
number of dialogues if you want to
actually change something that's really
closely held i guess there's a number of
different
um kind of offshoots from the socratic
method that have developed the last
couple years i know of like one's uh the
street epistemology and they're very
similar
on in this you know dialogue but it's
never um one of the main things is you
want both people to walk away from this
conversation in the end feeling like
that was a good conversation they both
had a good time well how about that's
what i'd like to do is and there are a
number of people recently that have been
involved and actually over the years and
trying to bring philosophy
including the street epistemology guys
uh to the street level and focusing more
on the methodology
and so one of my dreams is to get all of
these guys to come to a workshop in
athens and brainstorm ways that they
could kind of collaborate and come up
with like a synthesis of certain aspects
of their approach and you know describe
like the
alternative to saying would you guys
want to jump in a plane from
america and fly and sit and watch a
powerpoint presentation about plato's
cave would be to say would you like to
come for a weekend in athens and do a
skill and intensive skills training and
student epistemology or the socratic
method or and we use the socratic
questioning we use a thing that we call
socratic questioning and cognitive
therapy i should say
you know like you know people out there
but like screaming they're all screaming
at this
their computers right now greg going
what about socratic questioning in
cognitive therapy is the main technique
of cognitive therapy sort of is like so
we do we do that and also lawyers and in
different aspects of areas of education
socratic questioning is a thing and i
find though that there there's a lot of
people out there especially in education
who say they're doing socratic yeah it's
a credit question and basically all it
is is constantly asking questions yeah
they should spend some time reading
socratic dialogues you know from plato
and xenophon i know because they'd find
out that actually socrates does know a
lot of stuff he just deploys it in in
kind of you know strategic ways right
and also he has a method he has quite a
specific methodology for questioning
people
um you know and a lot of it revolves
around his concept of definitions
and uh
he'll tend to
um
you know he'll he'll try and identify
exceptions like he'll demonstrate to
people that the definitions are too
broad otherwise narrow but he's got a
number of strategies for doing that
technically it's a little bit different
from the questions we'd ask in cognitive
therapy but then like you said there's
other people that just use it to mean
asking those of questions and that
that's not quite so with the wrong right
and so we could get them and we could
say maybe there's more to the socratic
questioning malarkey than meets the eye
yeah and maybe there's there's a
philosophy behind it there are values
underlying it and maybe there's also
methodological uh strategies like that
you guys aren't aware of that could be
verbal strategies that you might be
employing cognitive strategies
um therapists educationalists could
benefit from that philosophers everybody
my i think could benefit more from
learning
critical thinking techniques including
these questioning methods so you know
there was something that that a long
time ago you and i had a conversation
and i don't remember whether it was
face-to-face or over
zoom and we were talking you brought up
the fact that so you you know you've
been a cognitive behavior therapist for
a long time you've written works on it
uh you've given a lot of uh talks and
you said nobody goes back and reads the
literature of cognitive behavior therapy
more than once they're not going to go
back and read ellis books or you know
burns is feeling better or things like
that but they will go back and read
epictetus discourses or seneca's letters
or marcus aurelius's meditations over
and over and over and over again yeah
and at that time you said i'm not quite
sure why it is i think it has to do with
the fact that there's a narrative there
there's like you know more more robust
things
and i was curious because i think
there's a parallel between this and what
you're doing with plato's academy or
there's something very robust happening
there
but going back to the thing about why
people don't read cbt stuff
like it's a classic but they do read
seneca or marcus aurelius
do you have any further thoughts on that
one
yeah what i said to you greg was that
people don't get tattoos
oh wait
right right and i thought i was kind of
i said that tentatively at first uh when
i was giving talks and things like i've
never met anyone with an albert ellis or
an rnt back tattoo yeah and i thought
i'm gonna look stupid here because
eventually somebody's going to go hey
that's rubbish i've got like aaron
beck's face tattooed on my elbow
right and i know i'm going to look
stupid i'm going to have to eat my words
and stuff like that but i've been saying
that for like 25 years now and i still
haven't met this guy that's got but
someone might just go out and get one
just to delete something purely to mess
with me now right yeah but i've never
met anyone with an albert ellis tattoo
or a cbt quote even really i've met
people with the serenity prayer tattooed
on them that doesn't count right
but i'm not going to give them that but
i've never heard seen anyone with like a
quote from
uh david burns who's feeling good tatted
on their
like you know backside or whatever but
you've got i mean i don't know if you've
seen how many people there are with
stoic tattoos starting with starting
with writing holiday right
like everyone like there's a guy that's
got a page where he just collects
pictures of stoic tattoos
like there's loads of them and people
keep sending them to me someone got a
tattoo on one of the illustrations from
my graphic novel and we haven't even
published it yet there's a good that's
got a tattooed a nice forearm
which is pretty wild so like people get
stoicism tattooed on them like now it
seems glib to say that right
for which i don't apologize but there's
a deeper point too which is that these
guys identify with us it's not just like
a technique to them it's a philosophy i
said that was one of the first things i
said yeah i started writing about
stoicism yeah it's a way of life like
when i wrote the philosophy cbt which is
my first book about this
um and even when i first began giving
talks and early articles that i wrote i
think the first article that i wrote
was
in like two i don't know when was it
2002 or something that was a long time
ago about stoicism
and uh like right at the very beginning
i remember saying a lot look
it's amazing how much similarity and
overlap there is between stoicism and
cbt right and people are oh we hadn't
thought of that it's a big revelation to
us right but even then i was also
qualifying that by saying but they're
not the same thing
because cbt and cbt practitioners will
be shouting at the computers when i say
that's right but cbt is a bunch of
techniques right and well no it's not
right okay it's a bit more than that
right but to a large extent it's a bunch
of techniques right right and there are
reasons why
because the industrial revolution like
so therapists have their niche
like like the guy that you know puts the
doors on cars in a factory or whatever
like it used to be everybody did
everything right and then we have
divisional labor like and now
psychotherapists and philosophers are
two different people
like whereas they used to be the same
guy right
so yeah like fine
right so now psychotherapists are like
we don't do philosophy like where our
job is we sit in a wee room with people
that are upset
and i mean obviously it's a little bit
more complicated than i'm making it
sound yeah right but we sit in a wee
room with like without windows like it's
kind of stuffy like with people that are
upset one after the other and then we
talk to them about their problems and
stuff like that and we teach them
techniques and we ask them these
questions and stuff like that but
generally speaking we can't teach them a
philosophy life and some therapists but
that's not true yes we do well they're
wrong right right because
like you
cannot indoctrinate clients into moral
values right as a boundary like
circumscribed around the role of the
therapist
like and
statism why maybe people don't
understand this like is a moral
philosophy
right and i did still work with clients
but only when they would come and say to
me i've read the book on stoicism mr
robertson and i'm really into could i
talk to you about ugly yeah sure but
clients people would say to me so how
did you do says when we were clients and
i would say i don't my because if they
walk in the door and they're a buddhist
or a muslim or a christian or marxist or
whatever it is i don't say sit down and
start believing that virtue is the only
true good and that'll make you feel
better like this they don't believe that
yeah this is a good place where we're
going to have to come to a close
uh wrap things up yeah we're going to
leave you the the chance to go out on
one of the we always end with a
passage and you've got two good ones
here so do you want to read them for us
and we're very happy to have you on here
too by the way so there's two quotes you
said i could have won but i chose to
from the meditations of mark civilians
so he says a fine reflection from plato
allegedly one who would converse about
human beings should look on all things
earthly as though from some point far
above upon herds armies and agriculture
marriages and divorces births and deaths
the clamour of law courts deserted
wastes alien peoples of every kind
festivals lamentations and markets for
agorai so this is marcus really is
describing what most people today would
call the view from above and then in
another passage he says remember that
your ruling center becomes invincible
when it withdraws into itself and rests
content with itself by virtue of this an
intelligence free from passions is a
mighty citadel for man has no stronghold
more secure to which he can retreat to
remain unassailable from that time
onwards
[Music]
so
you